hey guys it's Perry here with another
exclusive Collider interview for you
right now and this is a special on for a
number of reasons one I am a big fan of
the marvelous miss May as well
I am so excited to be sitting next to
Michael's Egan who is phenomenal in the
show but he's also a clatter fan sorry
is it okay that I just sure this is a
dream come true yeah I think your only
failure is that you've never seen my
Easter peeps Article III must have read
it at some point
I swear I'm a die-hard Collider fan so I
read it all you really shouldn't have
read that one though it's okay okay so I
wanted to start a little going back to
the beginning for you because I just
like hearing about what inspires someone
to jump into this crazy industry that
you're in was it any particular you know
a TV show a performance in a movie a
staged production that really said to
you I gotta be doing this I well I'm a
huge fan of TV in general I my parents
like TV they say that they don't but
they do and and I grew up watching a lot
of TV and we grew up going to theater
because I grew up right near New York
I'm from New Jersey so we went to shows
you know every every other week for the
most part but yeah I mean I I you know
I'm I'm a child of the 80s and I think
that movies were at their peak during
that period of time you had all the
spielberg you had you know ghostbusters
so I grew up watching Goonies like
Goonies was it for me I yeah I that was
that was my favorite at every day like
every day I watched Goonies so I think
that that really did get me into it was
like I want to be I will to be honest I
didn't just want to like be in a type of
Goonies type of movie I wanted to be
like in that movie you know somehow
somehow I would insert myself into that
movie but but yet I wanted to make
movies like that I wanted to you know
that was that's always been the dream so
I have to ask you now though but I like
when I like what movies and shows kind
of inspire me to like play scenarios out
and wonder how I would fare in a certain
situation just for the Goonies in
particular where we
like real you in that group of friends
yeah I definitely came up with a
character at the time you know when I
was a kid I don't I don't really
remember what that character was but he
was probably a cross between Mikey and
mouth but yeah I I that that movie was
everything for me I really I loved it
and I you know dad and et and and and
Ghostbusters like I said these are the
movies I remember seeing in a theater
and just being you know just that was it
I was I was just like it sucked in its a
good bunch of titles to name-drop yeah I
mean there's more
you know Ferris Bueller's Day Off I mean
you know all the classics Karate Kid
even yeah yeah back to your parents
really quickly have you shown them like
a lot of the stuff that you work on and
has that changed their opinion on TV at
all um well they've seen everything they
don't you know it they've literally seen
everything they they even stuff I don't
tell them that I'm in like they're like
guys watch this movie and you were in it
you know they they know they do their
homework so you know I think at first
they weren't really thrilled with me
becoming an actor but things worked out
and and I don't I don't they're not
really on my back anymore
about having a back-up plan so it's
understandable it's a tough industry to
make it in and it is I always think it's
one thing to say I want to be an actor
and it's another thing to say oh I am an
actor this is my profession do you
remember what the gig was that kind of
switch that over and made you believe it
was the real deal for you well I I kind
of started working pretty soon after I
graduated college so I got lucky I I
started working on the David Letterman
Show and I did a character called Dwight
the troubled teen and that I mean it was
it was really that that well it allowed
me to kind of survive in New York you
know I needed money for things like food
and and I didn't you know I didn't have
to ask my parents for any money not that
I ever really did but I I didn't and
that that kind of like ease the tension
you know they were like okay he's he's
okay
so so yeah I mean I think that was the
turning point that was when they were
like alright he's okay
very randomly cuz I'm a really big
Sopranos fan and I saw you had one
Sopranos credit on your IMDB page do you
remember shooting that episode what do
you think I forgot it yeah of course
well I mean what was it like were you
kind of just like hard to be there at
that point your career yeah and and and
it was such a small part and it was like
two lines but I really that to me that
that was like I remember when I did I
was like wow you made it man like hey
you're doing it you remember the lines
yeah I said well so my character I'll
set up the scene for you like my
character partygoer number one he show
up to some party that AJ is having and
like I didn't pay for a cup so he says
to me you didn't pay for that cuff but I
say so I'm like oh no he goes where'd
you get that cup and I go at the back at
the athletic department I guess cuz cup
you know yeah yeah yeah I think that's
what the line was I'm not really sure
actually just like that you remember it
that my because like those beginning
experiences are super important it's
like I make fun of the peeps article but
that's that's where it all started this
industry is so important Sopranos is
nothing to joke about I don't know no
and it was at the time it was my
favorite show is my parents favorite
show so it was that was pretty amazing
and III know even for that small little
part I auditioned for David chase so so
yeah it meant a lot
it really did that was the first time I
really like got a call saying you got
the part you know with with Letterman it
was it was it was like an audition where
was like 50 kids and and they just
whittled it down you know that night it
was just like they would send people
home and I was still left there was like
three of us and we had to audition in
front of the writers room and and then
they told me I got it so it wasn't you
know it wasn't like that agent calling
you yeah but uh but ya know that was a
big deal yeah despite the fact that it
was such a small part it was such a big
deal for me
so the next many years later big deal is
marvelous miss Mazal which i think i saw
it and i knew it was something special
and i can't believe what you guys
managed to accomplish in season two
after keeping after keeping setting the
bar so high in season one but back when
you first kind of accepted the role did
did you
have that special feeling did you know
that this had that extra spark well
first of all I didn't accept anything I
I wanted that so badly you know it
wasn't like will you do this shirt no I
wanted this part more than I've ever
wanted anything before I think and yeah
I knew I mean you know the reason why I
wanted it was because I knew how special
it was and I read that the pilot and I
you know I saw the time period and I saw
Lenny Bruce and how funny it was it was
so funny and and III have to be honest I
was never I never really watched Gilmore
Girls I still haven't watched it it I
watched like five minutes of one episode
and there was a scene where you know was
one of the Warner's that we do where
there's no cuts it just like you know
follows the characters and I saw one
episode where they're like walking
through a like a an office and all the
cubicles and they were like talking and
making right here making left there and
I was just having a panic attack so I
like I I don't think I should be
watching that even though I know that
that we have to do that stuff but he
kind of I know I was just rewatching the
alright so spoilers for anybody who is
not fully caught up on the show but I
was just re watching the last episode of
season 2 and just I mean in particular
it's like when you're moving around the
office say is it constantly in your head
I have to hit this specific mark at this
point because there's also so many 360
camera moves and I can't imagine
delivering my lines and also making sure
that I'm in the right place at the right
time yeah it's it's a dance you know
it's we show up and there's usually no
rehearsal or anything and and sometimes
they don't they don't tell you most of
the time they don't tell you that this
is all gonna be one shot like the
baseball scene they never told us that
was all going to be one shot has a long
scene for one shot it's actually even
longer they cut like a section off the
end so yeah is there movie magic in that
too because I don't even understand how
there's a camera in front of you and
you're hitting baseballs yeah well so
whenever the camera was in front of us
we had to throw the ball up and miss and
they they added that in I don't need all
the applause Nora because I love that
kind of stuff so I I'm always looking
for little details
don't you don't see a shred of what you
just explained I know I know yeah it's
pretty incredible they just painted away
that the ball on the ground they just
painted out but but yeah they don't even
tell you you know Amy I remember she was
setting up the shot and we were
rehearsing it and I was like wait is
this is this a water and she was like
maybe and you know and I I loved it I do
I despite the fact that I watched
Gilmore Girls and started panicking I
you know when I know that it's me doing
it it's it feels like theater to me and
so I I just I loved it I it you know
it's it's nerve-wracking but it's also
exciting and like there was one scene in
season 2 where I'm walking with Kevin
Pollak and we're walking through the
factory and you know we block it that
that morning we we come in at 6:00
whatever and we start figuring out and
that you know the cameraman our our
cameraman Jim McConkey he's he's
figuring out where he has to be and we
block it all out and then we just do it
until you get one and you all you need
is one all you need is one good take but
it is it is nerve-wracking because you
know that when if you screw up a line
you have to go back to the beginning but
still you there's no pressure really
because because you have you have a good
amount of time to get it right it's so
impressive that you guys pulled that off
speaking of the office though I did want
to ask about one specific prop because
the vertical is the office thing that
you mentioned um I think I was mostly
thinking about when he's just walking
from the main factory floor into his
personal office I think it's just you
know one of those one of those camera
moves that I'm like wow if one person
steps the wrong way or if I don't know
someone on the crew is in the wrong spot
the cameras spinning around and never
know yeah oh I can't even imagine yeah
that's where VFX comes in handy yeah but
I wanted to know about the vertigo
poster does that have any specific
meaning to you or is that something that
you know the the set designer just put
up there yeah I don't know no I do I
know exactly what you're talking about
but yeah I that was just something that
that was just there when you know when I
when they built the set and there's
actually a Bix Beiderbecke poster who's
a jazz musician I really like so that
that was cool for me so I also wanted to
talk a little bit about season three I
know you can't say too
but can you speak it all to the director
lineup that you have is it all the the
returnees from the last two seasons yeah
Amy and Dan pretty much switch off and
there's one episode directed by Dan
adieus who's a kind of a prolific TV
director he's done a lot including
Sopranos so um so yeah I mean usually
there's only maybe one guest director
per season and that's I think typically
because the Amy and Dan kind of need to
catch up with writing and you know
figuring out where they're gonna film
you know scouting and whatever so it's
just there's a lot but it they still
they still switch off they you know and
and Dan I think did like three episodes
in a row this last time or two Episode I
he wrote you know I mean they just it's
nuts
it really is it's nuts I don't know how
they do it because they write as they go
along so it's not all written before we
start shooting it's like you know the
first episodes written mm-hmm and then
and then it they they have to kind of
keep up but they do that I think they've
been doing it for a long time and this
is how they operate and it works
considering how they operate is there
any instance in the past where you kind
of pictured a specific trajectory for
Joel and then when you got the script
for upcoming episodes it was something
entirely different
well I mean I still don't know what his
trajectory is I don't know I didn't know
in the first season you know there's
that the scene towards the end in the
last episode where he beats up the guys
and you know says she's good I didn't
know that was coming I didn't I didn't
know that he was gonna have that
redeeming scene III I never asked for
them to like redeem him it was a
surprise and it was a really beautiful
surprise I loved it but yeah I don't I
don't know anything I don't ask I don't
I like to be surprised I like I like
yeah I just like reading their scripts
and and not knowing what's gonna happen
it's it's it's exciting for me Rachel
tries telling me stuff like she she does
she does she have all the secrets not
all the secrets for sure but she asks
she likes to ask them what's gonna
happen and then she'll try to tell me I
don't want to give away anything I mean
certainly not for season at the end
season two there's at the very end of
season two there's that this scene well
I mean if you haven't watched it by now
people need to catch up because people
need to put the third season on the
counter December 6 don't forget but but
uh there's the scene you know where she
comes to my office and yeah we have a
little makeout session and she wanted
Rachel was kept trying to tell me what
was gonna happen I was like don't tell
me just don't tell me and and and then
when I got the script she was telling me
that like at the end something good
happens and when I got the script I'm
reading reading reading and and I'm like
at the end and there's like two pages
left I was like what the hell was she
talking about like I'm I'm not even in
it anymore and then there's that thing
so it was it was that was a welcome
surprise are you guys at the point where
everybody out there when you do these
interviews is pronouncing Mazal right no
it's just like breaking my heart the
more that I want oh yeah yeah no no
Maisel Mizell yeah no ISIL is the one
that I think I saw the most oh really
yeah may I heard the most Mizell people
still sit there like I'm such a fan of
mrs. Mizell and I'm like well you're not
that much of a fan but yeah no it's okay
I don't care
wait now okay so I'm gonna see you again
in so we're taping this little early
admittedly I'm gonna see you again in
New York for the proper junket okay cool
very curious what is the question that
you guys have all gotten the most about
the show and is there anything that
you're itching to talk about that no
one's really asked you at this point you
know I don't know so many people asked
about the baseball scene like I mean
like on the street ya know people people
ask about that one all they're just
there's something very satisfying about
like the pitch perfect crack of a
baseball bat like hitting the ball
perfectly I don't know something about
that always gets me so that that scene
like I feel the satisfaction of that by
watching it yeah
in terms of like character you know
people who asked like oh what the you
know are you well people always ask if
we're gonna get back together that's
that's the way the secrets though no no
of course not but that that is the
number one question people always ask
like are you guys getting but even my
six-year-old niece asked me the other
day she's like are you guys gonna get
back together I was like I'm I can't
tell you for so you know I can't tell
her she's six I you know
so tell all the other people in your
first grade class so I know I did but
what do I want them to ask or maybe if
you had the opportunity to ask your
other your co cast a question what would
it be and why ooh I don't know I mean I
just like is this III you know somebody
like Tony Shalhoub I would ask like is
this is this like the best job you've
ever had because I think it is so I
don't know you know like because he's
worked in so many things but he looks
like he's having so much fun
he really does yeah so uh but III Kevin
Pollak told me that that this was the
best job he's ever had he's he's
prolific too so I don't know I don't
know what I would ask I would believe it
there's something about the energy of
the show and like the love of the family
and love between the characters that's
that's infectious it just like it's a
show that it has some really deep
moments but it just leaves you happy
good and hopefully nothing changes
because we're all having a great time I
I believe it's it's in a good spot right
now I'm written for you guys I wanted to
do before we wrap this up and give you a
little Abe Wiseman interrogation right
now so it's a rapid-fire
I'm removing his religion and politics
question but I'm gonna start with what
are your hobbies acting um I like
baseball
I like watching baseball I don't know I
don't want to have too many hobbies uh I
like I like well I like TV
you know I does that count as a hug I
think that counts as a hobby yeah I like
watching TV yeah I do like watching TV
and I like theater I like going to the
theater but like if I if I had to choose
a hobby that I'm not already partaking
in I think metal detecting because I
really I've been watching a lot of
YouTube videos of these guys with their
metal detectors and they find old coins
and I just find it so fascinating that's
so random and I kind of love it yeah
like I want to try it it goes back to my
goony days that makes a whole lot of
sense I think I'm a little data and
Mikey so if there was some sort of
gadget that I could use in order to
solve something I would be all about it
so Abe's next question is what
percentage of time are you spending on
your hobbies
well if it's TV it's probably like 90%
unfortunately but wait what shows are
you really into right now you know I'm
trying to think well I just watched the
first episode of the mandalorian ooh
yeah I liked it you liked it yeah I did
and I just finished this show I don't
you probably haven't heard of it but
it's it's it's on Netflix it's this
Israeli show called schnitzel and it's
about a Hasidic family growing living in
Jerusalem and and it's pretty incredible
it's like one of the most incredible
shows I've ever seen yeah you should you
should it's it's it's something I think
everybody can enjoy it has subtitles you
know you gotta get past that subtitles
are fine there's nothing like they're
fine you know I'm actually somebody
who's like house subtitles alright but
people kept telling me about this show
and I watched it and it's just
absolutely amazing
okay it's all right who knew I'm trying
to think what else I mean I've always
you know I always watch I was watching
Game of Thrones I was a game of Thrones
fan yeah I haven't started Watchmen yet
but I will
Watchmen Watchmen is well worth I know I
hurt here I mean now it's all HBO but I
was telling everybody that I am obsessed
succession oh yeah yeah I mean I'm not I
haven't watched season 2 yet okay so I'm
like halfway through season two okay and
I know that the end is right around the
corner and I'm already getting very
upset about it oh yeah there's gonna be
more see there's gonna be more but like
where we're in a world where you you you
binge and like you can have all this
content your fingertips it's like I've
forgotten how to wait and I know but I
do I like waiting I do I it's like it
gives you something to look forward to
okay I don't know at least for me like I
liked that about Game of Thrones it's
like you talked about or Mad Men you
know you talked about it like all we're
breaking bad's I feel like my ability to
wait changes every other day right now
I'm very impatient but tomorrow I might
be okay with that yeah well we're an
impatient Society I think that's why
we're so into binging that's yeah that's
definitely the case I definitely have
some of that his next question is are
you a dog or a cat man I'm allergic to
cats so dogs I guess I don't have it
Rachel keeps asking telling me to get a
dog her dogs are something else they're
adorable yeah they're fun but I I did
promise her if the show got picked up
that I would get a dog and the show got
picked up for two seasons I still have
not got a dog now we're done with the
third season yeah so looked into it yeah
I've looked at pictures of dogs I
haven't really invested that much time
into it but I I will eventually it's
just yeah I just have to you know it's
tough so you know she's able to do it
even with two dogs but like I I've never
had a dog my entire life I wanted but I
my parents wouldn't let me so yeah so I
you know it's gonna take some getting
used to and but I will I promised her
and hopefully someday it's well worth
yeah two more questions actually three
more if I'm gonna finish his quiz your
favorite authors oh well one of my
favorite books was has always been
Grapes of Wrath so I like Steinbeck but
I like I like nonfiction I read a lot of
like biographies of people and and yeah
like history kind of stuff like I really
enjoy that so so there's not like one
specific you know fiction author that
I'm just like voraciously reading or
anything like that I'm kind of just all
over the place if you ever take a break
from the biographies I recommend going
to Stephen King oh no I mean I grew up
leading Stephen King yeah I've just been
up to my eyeballs and Stephen King's
work since the first it movie came out
in 2017 and I'm like oh you Scharffen
and I had so many people all my life
recommend that I read his stuff but I
just didn't read and all of a sudden I
started and I can't stop no I read I
read it when I was in I think like 7th
or 8th grade and it freaked me out yeah
yeah but I liked I also liked his his
like kind of more serious stuff like the
the different seasons book with Stand By
Me and Shawshank Redemption yeah like I
remember reading that and yeah I loved
Stephen King I was just
about that the other day like that's in
terms of you know scary movies cuz I
don't really enjoy those torture porn
kind of movies I like I like the Stephen
King kind of stuff where there's a story
and you know just it just freaks you out
like maximum world-building and
character development into everything he
writes and that's that's why it kind of
like sinks in and it sticks with you
yeah I never had the stand I haven't
touched that I'm a little intimidated by
a thousand-page book yeah but I've
always wanted to I loved the miniseries
like years ago I loved that so maybe
someday I'll get to that right in the
middle of a running man right now oh
cool yeah I read that it's a good one
yeah favorite baseball team Yankees okay
it was an easy I know that's that's
lightning for you yeah I mean I'm a Mets
person at heart
uh-huh but I will always root for both
New York teams because New York is the
best okay faith this is so random I
don't think are gonna have an answer to
this one but he asks it in the show
favorite radio shows favorite radio
shows a podcast or something I'm not
even I don't even really really listen
to podcasts all that much I should I
know everybody's always telling me but I
I I don't like when I go to the gym I
just listen to music you know people are
on the on the ellipticals listening in
podcast and I just I just I don't know I
kind of I don't like to think too much
when I'm working out and will recommend
my dad wrote a porno I'm actually not a
talking about cast listener myself but
that is one of the more recent ones that
I actually did start listening to after
it was recommended to me and it's
hilarious
it's not all about his dad writing a
porno right no it's they read the porno
that his dad wrote in every single
episode is a different chapter oh yeah
it's it's pretty hilarious
Wow and then they'll have like these
little in between episodes where guests
come on and just talk about the content
oh okay well maybe I should do that yeah
yeah it's another thing that will keep
you very busy and brighten your day and
probably make the work out a lot easier
okay all right we do have to say goodbye
so much for your time today and your
swing and by everybody out there please
do not forget to watch the marvelous
missus Mazal it's going to be available
season 3 on December
six then we might have spoiled some
stuff for the prior two seasons but if
you haven't seen them like what are you
waiting for go watch that show it's
phenomenal really you are fantastic in
it thank you guys so much for watching
this interview do not leave without
liking and sharing it and we'll see you
soon with more of them